EVERY NOW AND AGAIN I LIKE TO
CHECK IN WITH OUR GOOD FRIENDS
ON THE FOX NEWS NETWORK-- OR--
OR AS YOUR GRANDPARENTS CALL IT
"THE REAL NEWS."
AND TO BE FRANK, OFTENTIMES THIS
SHOW IS CRITICAL OF FOX.
BUT ONLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
TERRIBLE.
( LAUGHTER )
LIKE SOMETIMES ALMOST SHOCKINGLY
TERRIBLE.
FOR INSTANCE, TWO WEEKS AGO, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RELEASED A
REPORT ON THE FERGUSON, MISSOURI
POLICE DEPARTMENT SHOOTING OF
MICHAEL BROWN.
BASICALLY EXONERATING OFFICER
DARREN WILSON AND DEBUNKING THE
HANDS UP, DON'T SHOOT,
NARRATIVE.
AND THEN THEY RELEASED A SECOND
D.O.J. REPORT STATING THAT THE
FERGUSON, MISSOURI ROUTINELY
VIOLATES THE CONSTITUTION AND
FEDERAL LAW WITH A PATTERN OF
RACIAL BIAS, UNREASONABLE FORCE,
INTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION AND
MISTREATMENT OF DETAINEES
WRONGS BORNE DISPROPORTIONATELY
BY AFRICAN AMERICANS.
BUT ON FOX-- YOU'RE GOING TO
LOVE THIS-- DESPITE THEIR
24-HOUR SCHEDULE, THEY REALLY
ONLY HAD TIME FOR THE ONE
REPORT.
>> THE D.O.J. NOW ADMITTING
HANDS UP, DON'T SHOOT, NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FED A
NARRATIVE.
>> PROTESTERS WHO HAVE BEEN
RUNNING AROUND THIS COUNTRY
TELLING A LIE.
>> THE TSUNAMI OF MISINFORMATION
AND INNUENDO.
BONE-HEADED NONFACT-BASED
RHETORIC
>> IT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> IT DID NOT HAPPEN THAT WAY.
WILSON HAS BEEN EXONERATED.
LET'S MOVE ON.
>> Jon: LET'S MOVE ON!
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOUND
THAT THE FLASHPOINT INCIDENT FOR
PROTESTS DID NOT HAPPEN THE WAY
SOME THOUGHT.
ALTHOUGH, IN THE SECOND REPORT,
THEY DID ALSO DOCUMENT A TOWER
OF RACIALLY BASED KINDLING WOOD,
YEARS OF UNREASONABLE FORCE
LIGHTER FLUID, AND DAILY TOSSED
LIT CIGARETTE BUTTS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
THAT COULD EASILY LEND ITSELF TO
THE FLASHPOINT.
BUT AS THE FIRE SAFETY WARDENS
OF FOX SUGGEST, ( BLEEP ) IT,
LET'S JUST MOVE ON.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT HERE'S THE THING-- THE ANGER
IS STILL THERE.
THE PEOPLE COULDN'T MOVE ON AT
FOX.
THEY-- THEY DEMANDED RESTITUTION
AT FOX.
>> WHY ISN'T THE MEDIA, WHICH
PEDALED THAT NARRATIVE,
APOLOGIZING?
>> OBAMA, SHARPTON-- THEY SHOULD
BE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
INCENDIARY RHETORIC.
>> FANNING THE FLAMES, RUSHING
TO JUDGMENT.
>> BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS.
>> THE DAMAGE WAS DONE. THE
INFLAMATORY RHETORIC WAS USED.
>> WE SAW MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
SAYING, "HAND UP, DON'T SHOOT."
AND IF ONE OF THEM HAS SO FAR
APOLOGIZED FOR MISLEADING
AMERICA, WE HAVEN'T HEARD IT.
>> Jon: I HAVE NOT RECEIVED
A SINGLE "I'M BEAR-Y SORRY FOR
IGNITING RACIAL CONFLICTS"
GREETING CARDS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ONE!
THE LESSON FOX NEWS IS GETTING
AT IS VERY CLEAR-- WOULDN'T IT
BE NICE IF PEOPLE WHO JUMPED TO
CONCLUSIONS AND PEDALED A FALSE
DIVISIVE, ANGER-STOKING
NARRATIVE HAD TO APOLOGIZE FOR
MISLEADING AMERICA?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
NOW, NOW HERE'S WHERE THE
( BLEEP ) GETS REAL.
I WONDER IF THERE'S AN ANALOGOUS
EVENT WHERE WE COULD
TEST FOX'S FEALTY TO THIS
PRINCIPLE OF RESTITUTION
FOR AGGRIEVEMENT?
>> DOES THE WORD BENGHAZI RING A
BELL?
>> A BUNCH OF NEW QUESTIONS
ABOUT BENGHAZI.
>> BENGHAZI.
>> BENGHAZI, BENGHAZI, BENGHAZI.
>> Jon: FIRST OF ALL,
BENGHAZI ISN'T "BEATLEJUICE."
YOU DON'T SAY IT THREE TIMES.
BUT IF YOU INSIST, OKAY, LET'S
USE THAT EXAMPLE.
IT'S A TRAGIC EVENT WHERE
AMERICANS DIED, LIKE FERGUSON.
BUT IF THE ANALOGY IS TO HOLD,
WHO WILL PLAY THE ROLE OF
NATION-DIVIDING, ANGER-STOKING,
RHETORITICIAN BEFORE THE
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATION WAS COMPLETED?
>> SPECIAL REPORT INVESTIGATES
DEATH AND DECEIT IN BENGHAZI.
>> SUSAN RICE WILLINGLY WENT
ALONG AND LIED ON SUNDAY CHAT
SHOWS.
>> THE C.I.A. WARNED THAT THERE
MIGHT BE AN ATTACK ON THE 9/11
ANNIVERSARY.
>> DURING THE ATTACK, THEY
DIDN'T SEND HELP THAT WAS
WAITING IN TRIPOLI, C-130, TO
ASSIST THESE GUYS.
>> COMING UP, THEY COULD HAVE
SAVED FOUR AMERICANS, BUT
INSTEAD, OUR GOVERNMENT TOLD
THEM TO STAND DOWN.
>> Jon: SO BASICALLY YOU'RE
SAYING THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TOLD ITS
MILITARY-- IF I WANT TO PUT THIS
IN A CATCHY, PROTESTY KIND OF
PHRASE-- STAND DOWN, DON'T
SHOOT.
AND FOX DIDN'T RESTRICT ITS
ANGER STOKING TO WORDS, BECAUSE
LET'S FACE IT, THEIR OLDER
VIEWERS WHO ARE HEARD OF
HEARING, ALSO HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
MAD, SO SCARY OPENS AND
THAT BURNING BENGHAZI FOOTAGE IN
A SEMICONTINUOUS LOOP
LIKE SOME KIND OF
FOX NEWS YULE LOG.
( LAUGHTER )
OH, THEY'RE RUNNING THE BURNING
COMPOUND FOOTAGE AGAIN.
IT SEEMS LIKE BENGHAZ-MAS COMES
EARLIER AND EARLIER EVERY YEAR.
BUT, OF COURSE, UNLIKE FERGUSON
PROTESTERS, FOX WASN'T BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE AND DIVISIVE.
THEY JUST WANTED THE TRUTH.
>> WE HAVE UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
ABOUT BENGHAZI.
>> THERE ARE GLARING QUESTIONS
THAT ARE UNANSWERED.
>> QUESTIONS STILL REMAIN
UNANSWERED.
>> THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
STAND DOWN ORDERS AND SO ON, AND
HERE WE ARE ALL THE TIME LATER,
WE DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS.
>> SO WE STILL DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWERS.
>> FOUR AMERICANS ARE DEAD, AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF UNANSWERRED
QUESTIONS.
>> Jon: WELL, YOUR SENTENCE
CONSTRUCTION SAYS I JUST WANT TO
KNOW BUT YOUR TONE SAYS WHY THE
PRESIDENT HAD AN AMBASSADOR
WHACKED.
WELL, FINALLY ON NOVEMBER 21,
2014, THEY GOT THEIR ANSWERS
FROM AN EXHAUSTIVE REPORT FROM
THE REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ANSWERING
THOSE MANY QUESTIONS-- DID
SUSAN RICE GO ON TV AND TRY TO
DECEIVE ANYONE?
REPORT SAYS NO.
DID THE ADMINISTRATION IGNORE
CREDIBLE WARNINGS ABOUT THAT
DAY'S ATTACK?
REPORT SAYS NO.
WAS THERE A STAND-DOWN ORDER OR
FAILURE TO RESCUE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND SEND RESCUE
PLANES?
REPORT SAYS NO.
WAS THERE A MASSIVE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY COVER UP, THE REPORT SAYS
NO, NOT C.I.A., NOT F.B.I., NONE
OF THEM.
WHICH MEANS ALL THESE ELEMENTS
OF THE TWO YEAR BENGHAZI
RAGE-GASM -- WERE, WHAT
DO YOU, WHAT DO YOU CALL IT?
>> TSUNAMI OF MISINFORMATION AN
INNUENDO.
>> Jon: RIGHT, RIGHT. RIGHT.
>> BONE-HEADED, NON-FACTED-BASED
RHETORIC.
>> Jon: YES! YES, YES, YES!
THAT!
RIGHT, IT'S ALL THOSE
THINGS.
SO IT WOULD ONLY FOLLOW THAT
JUST LIKE FOX DEMANDED OF ANY
PROTESTER WHO SAID, "HANDS UP,
DON'T SHOOT," THE CORRECTION
ACTION FOR NO STAND DOWN DON'T
SHOOT FOR FOX NEWS NOW
WOULD BE TO--
>> WHY ISN'T THE MEDIA WHICH
PEDALED THAT NARRATIVE
APOLOGIZING?
>> Jon: YES!
YES!
WHY NOT?
MWA!
OH ERIC, THAT'S SO TRUE.
YES!
AND SO, IN THE FATEFUL DAYS
FOLLOWING THAT REPUBLICAN HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE REPORT,
WHAT DID THE FOX SAY?
♪ ♪ ♪
>> Jon: YUNG-YUNG-YUNG!
IN FACT, OTHER THAN A COUPLE OF
HALF-HEARTED EFFORTS TO
( BLEEP ) ON THE REPUBLICAN-LED
REPORT, ITS CONTENTS WENT
LARGELY UNNOTICED ON FOX.
EVEN MEGYN KELLY WHO WAS PRIOR
TO THAT DESPERATELY SEARCHING
FOR ANSWERS HAD THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHAIR MIKE ROGERS ON
HER SHOW TWO WEEKS AFTER HE
RELEASED THE BENGHAZI REPORT AND
NEVER ASKED HIM ABOUT IT ONCE,
NOT ( BLEEP ) ONCE.
YES, THE NETWORK, WHO USED THE
WORD "BENGHAZI" LIKE A CLUBHOUSE
PASSWORD, THE OFFICIAL
REPUBLICAN-DOMINATED HOUSE
REPORT ON BENGHAZI WAS THE ONLY
NEWS STORY IN TWO YEARS THAT
DIDN'T REMIND THEM TO TALK ABOUT
BENGHAZI.
( LAUGHTER )
WHICH BRINGS US, ONCE AGAIN, TO
OUR MAIN POINT OF RESPECT AND
APPRECIATION.
THE BEAUTY THAT IS THE UGLINESS
OF FOX NEWS.
THEY DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
ANGER DIVISIVENESS, WHILST
HOLDING THEMSELVES ENTIRELY
UNACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ANGER
AND DIVISIVENESS.
FOR TWO YEARS, THEY USED
BENGHAZI AS SHORTHAND, AS A
SYMBOL FOR THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF
A CORRUPT, LYING, TYRANNICAL,
POSSIBLY MURDEROUS OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE, KIND OF LIKE OTHER PEOPLE
USED "HANDS UP, DON'T SHOOT AS A
SYMBOL FOR SYSTEMIC RACISM.
AND THERE'S REALLY ONLY ONE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
PHENOMENA-- SYSTEMIC RACISM
ACTUALLY EXISTS.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK